to quote a famous member of our
committee let's do it while we're young
weather's nice i want to go home
open the um
session the committee meeting on the
health and human services oversight
committee and would the clerk please
call the roll
senator gray's conflicted with another
committee actually too he said but
tough to be popular
here
president
representative mcmahon here
representative marsh is here
and i will note that representative
nelson and representative murphy are
absent
thank you very much
please look at the minutes from the last
meeting you should have received and
compliments to the clerk for taking
good
thorough minutes
motion to approve the minutes as
presented mr chairman
and the second by representative soloway
a few minutes more to read the minutes
and ask any questions
you may have
um
looks like everybody's had a chance to
re-read them and if there are no
questions
all in favor of approving the minutes i
i proposed
thank you the next meeting
one extension
you abstend i wasn't there
okay
representative senator gaida abstains
because he wasn't at that meeting
the next meeting of uh the committee
will be friday may 20th
that moves it off our normal fourth
friday of the month
because
the fourth friday is the beginning of
memorial day weekend and because there's
another
committee that meets in the morning that
would clash with this one
we usually revert to one in the
afternoon so
note may 20th at 1 pm for our next
meeting
chair calls upon the commissioner to
come up and make a report
good morning
lori shibanet commissioner of health and
human services just going to give you a
short briefing about some of the things
that have developed within the
department over the last month
i'm going to start with mental health
you probably have seen that we've
brought forward a budget and a contract
for a third party operator at hampstead
hospital
the contract the budget got approved at
governor and council on wednesday the
third party contract was tabled
requesting more time to review
so we're doing reach out to the
counselors to make sure all their
questions have been answered we are
scheduled to close on hampstead around
the middle of may there's no date
certain yet
so we're hoping to have that contract
prior to
that close or it will obviously push off
the close of that facility
the third-party contractor
recovery solutions is meeting with the
staff at hampstead hospital the intent
is for them to offer employment to all
of the staff there
the leadership team at hampstead
hospital will be state employees the
long-time chief operating officer at
hampstead has accepted the state
position of ceo for that hospital
so she will be staying in place and we
are currently recruiting for the other
leadership positions at the hospital
so recovery solution is meeting with the
line staff now
it is very important that we create an
environment of stability for them if
this
goes on for several weeks
line staff start to feel unstable and
start looking for other jobs and we
don't want that to happen we want to
keep them in-house
so
so that's the update on hampstead the
other one question on hampstead hospital
from the chair you know what my question
will be because i've already received
okay the tax payment
that is in the budget that has been
approved so it was in the hampstead
budget that was approved by governor and
council on uh wednesday i talked to
representative guthrie about it also on
wednesday the way that uh the way that
the state typically does payment in lieu
of taxes is they include it with house
bill 2 every year so that way it can be
adjusted
um so i let representative guthrie know
that on wednesday also but we will
follow up with the town of hampstead for
another discussion if somebody could
shoot me a memo to that i think i've got
it here
so i i will be talking to my friends in
finance about three or four million
dollars and they'll have a big laugh and
we'll compromise on something that's
probably reasonable
thank you for keeping me updated sure
on hampstead hospital representative
edwards
okay so i'm a little unfamiliar with the
philosophy behind the state paying
in lieu of taxes
is the philosophy that
we pay a hundred percent of what would
have been gathered in the property tax
or is there some other way we look at it
and there's a different amount that's
calculated i think that every case is
looked at individually in this case we
are paying the tax amount because the
tam state hospital is such a large
provider of tax revenue for a small town
like hampstead my house being the other
one
so
when when we looked at the conversion
from a private entity to state entity
the town of hampstead was in line to
lose a substantial amount of tax revenue
and we wanted to make sure to make them
whole for that so approximately 150 000
is what they what they um have always
received in the past couple years so
that is what is in the budget
to pay them in lieu of taxes other
towns and cities receive payment in lieu
of taxes um i think smaller but uh but
they do city of concord being one
senator rosenberg
thank you
um commissioner what is the
connection between recovery solutions
and well well path which is the name i
saw on the contract sure well recovery
solutions is a
subdivision of of well path so they have
two different lines of business one is
under corrections and one is under
psychiatric care most of the news and
most of the negative press that you've
seen about wellpath is around their
corrections division not around their
healthcare division
so we've been very clearly trying to
make that distinction for for folks so
that they don't get the two lines of
business confused
with any new contractor coming to the
state providing care for such a
vulnerable population
regardless of their litigation history
or their quality history
we always put a contract in place that
is maximally protective of the state and
the people we serve so this contract
specifically
90 of the contract is a pass-through
contract so there's no incentive to cut
corners save money or otherwise it's a
direct pass-through
the leadership team including the
director of compliance which is the
director of quality of care is all state
employees
so we have
uh recovery solution providing the
clinical care and state employees
providing the oversight and the
leadership in that hospital and then we
obviously have the hampstead staff that
have been in that building for decades
know that the quality of care they've
always provided
and we'll make sure that we continue to
provide that so i feel very comfortable
that we have uh oversight and monitoring
there to ensure good quality care
anything else on hampstead hospital
please continue your report um hca is
the other big mental health investment
that we're uh
we're
kind of sitting on right now
it had been on governor and council
agenda
three times it was removed every time
for not having um support for that for
that accept and expend
so at this point the department is
negotiating for terms of the contract
with hca and plans to bring back both
the accept and expend and the contract
together to governor and council in the
coming months
there is still widespread support uh
to
that that we need additional inpatient
beds especially a diversity of beds that
include adult and gero psych and and
children and hca is certainly offering
that
so
although that has been removed from
agendas at governor and council we do
expect to bring it back probably before
the summer
in relations to covid we're all seeing
the number of covet cases
starting to increase again we're seeing
hospitalizations increase again although
not as substantial as before
so we're all keeping an eye on that
that's across the country just not in
new hampshire
and hoping that the combination of both
our high vaccination rates and our
natural immunity rates is going to keep
the serious illness at bay if we have
another surge
question mr chair question
representative uh yes could you report
on wastewater testing in new hampshire
yes it was next on my list
um wastewater testing
the acceptance pen was approved by
fiscal committee last meeting we are
contracting with unh right now
uh the the plan is to initially utilize
unh to do wastewater testing at between
20 and 25 public wastewater facilities
across the state that will convert to
our public health lab sometime in the
fall the federal government has given us
additional guidance on one of our grants
that allow us to purchase the equipment
to do wastewater testing not just on
covid but other infectious disease also
so we will be using unh probably through
november and then we will convert to
public health lab
and then my last thing that i would like
to report out on monday this past monday
we held a commissioner's roundtable for
healthcare workforce at the griponi
center sponsored by the endowment for
health we had about 70 healthcare
leaders
in one room and had table discussions on
what we wanted to do and what we wanted
to prioritize going forward
both in the area of recruitment and
retention a lot of good ideas came out
of that jsi was our synthesizers for
that meeting so they're putting together
a report i do expect three to five
actionable items that i'll put a
proposal together for in the next 60
days that i'll be able to bring forward
on workforce recruitment and retention
representative edwards
uh thank you mr chair um so
so several times the topic of workforce
recruitment and retention has come up
and we've i think we've tried to do a
few things
what what what do you think may come out
of this round that's unique or different
than what we've seen in the past what
what's the great new idea yeah i well i
i don't think there's necessarily a new
idea i think there's the opportunity to
braid some funding sources to to execute
some of the older ideas
upfront scholarship payment especially
for line workers like nursing assistants
really really um important
these are people that go through a
six-week program that
pay between twenty five hundred and four
thousand 000 to go through that
oftentimes they don't have the money up
front although it gets reimbursed in the
end so providing that upfront payment
that'll get reimbursed eventually
we talked a lot about
paying wages why people go to school
which is used in other other industries
for example law enforcement is a great
example
law enforcement officers get hired by
the police department put through the
police academy and paid wages while they
go through
and then really about campaigning and
marketing around um diversity and
inclusion of of getting different people
into the healthcare sector and providing
career paths to grow within the
healthcare sector you know a lot of
people will tell stories and in
part part of the round table was we had
a student speaking and then we had a
long-term veteran speaking
in the l a that spoke has been an lna
for was an lna for 10 years her name is
lexi and she has always wanted to be a
nurse and she has no ability to go to
nursing school because most people need
to pay their bills and provide a life
for themselves and can't afford to stop
working to go to school
so she gave a great example of this
untapped resource of people that want to
be nursing nurses or other health care
professionals and just are not able to
take that next step so we're really
looking to our health care providers our
hospitals our nursing homes um our
non-profit providers like the endowment
for health and the charitable foundation
to help us braid some funding to get
some of those people into school and
into the
workforce um commissioner this is one of
the things that the
medical facility of which i'm ceo has
done we've paid for people to get their
training in exchange for
and it has made it possible to get
people into the workforce so this is a
good thing yes
representative edwards follow-up um so i
just want to throw an idea at you um
given that we have a law that basically
lets all of our
military folks with an appropriate uh
training and and health care come into
the state and be licensed automatically
i i i would just uh
ask that we think about
doing some recruiting to military
folks who are going to be getting
discharged and wanting to figure out
where they're going to go with the rest
of their life um we we love having uh
veterans come on to our our payroll for
sure in in the health care sector they
bring a unique experience i don't think
general michelade's wants me out
recruiting his staff but
um no i mean people who are currently uh
deployed outside and belong to somebody
other than new hampshire yeah there are
things like the army times the air force
times there are there are newspapers
targeted at the military and maybe a
little ad
campaign
we might be able to incentivize people
to move to new hampshire when they don't
really have any other idea where they
want to go sure great suggestion
when a person gives the general his or
her last salute pivots and walks to the
front gate you'll be there i'll be there
right
senator geider thank you mr chairman
are you all coordinating with uh
commissioner arlinghaus das who's also
now got some
new impetus for recruiting and retention
yes absolutely we work hand in hand with
them and um oplc
on the regulatory burdens that come
along with healthcare licensing
representative sullivan uh thank you mr
chairman good morning commissioner uh
just a quick question is the community
college system a party to your
discussions oh yes community college
system all of the universities both
private and public have all been at the
table with us
any other questions about anything
within the department
great
thank you so much thank you i do have
one comment mr chair you may have a
comment
senate bill 376 that established the
funding for mental health training cit
training for police officers is passed
the house yesterday
and it's now before finance in the house
and we have a work session today which i
plan to attend great thank you
the one on
safety
for medical workers
let me just say i think i got as much as
i could get and i'm not satisfied and
want to work with various people over
the summer
representative edwards uh brought up
some concerns that he had had in that
bill what i can tell you is that
you know this has been five years in the
making around workplace safety for
health care workers and i i think that
you know logically we talked about when
when a health care worker gets battered
or assaulted in their workplace
logically we assume that the law
enforcement's going to come in and press
charges and and arrest that person and
and what we find in health care is that
actually doesn't happen as much as you
think it does
and i i think that is the impetus for
this type of bill um i i did tell
representative edwards that i would go
back and review any amendments and he
was going to send me his thoughts on it
and i will do that
good good
sometimes you
get as much as you can and not push for
more than you can because then you get
nothing
but we'll be back
senator gray
um i feel i have to comment i was the
chair of the committee plus the sponsor
of the bill
it is very important to me that that
data collection stuff takes place
it is very important to me that the
de-escalation techniques happen in the
hospital and it is very important to me
that the officers
you know
execute those de-escalation techniques i
believe that with those two
de-escalation techniques happening for
an individual that we won't have a need
for warrantless arrest
but
it should be there
and
as the chair has said before
we'll look at it afterward
certainly in deference to representative
edwards we want to get as close as we
can
to not needing that but it is a tool
senator i think you know i i agree with
you on the data collection i think a lot
of this was brought on by an increase of
injuries at new hampshire hospital
because they are so publicly reported at
governor and council and uh there were a
lot of questions when we continued to
bring
really serious injuries of our staff
forward at those meetings and what
became obvious is that we didn't know
how often that was happening in other
healthcare facilities besides new
hampshire hospital but what we do know
is the nurses association and the
medical society and all of the other
health care practitioners very much
agree and support
um moving forward with something that
helps protect our health care workers
and and in all health care settings not
just hospitals nursing homes home care
everywhere
representative edwards
um
well okay so division three at three
o'clock begins the process of looking at
what passed the house in
your bill senate bill 458 you know that
the amendment
uh uh
deleted
the uh criminal justice code
aspect the warrantless arrests
um and i hope that that gets brought
back
in its own bill
because if we're having these kinds of
issues where police will not arrest
somebody with witnesses saying there was
a battery
that's not just a health care problem
that's a new hampshire public safety
issue that i think we would like to
address more broadly and
so uh
so i i'm i'm happy to speak with you
senator gray on um
what what i'm thinking about the bill
and what we might do that
meets your objectives
all right
anything else for the commissioner
thank you commissioner thank you
chair recognizes representative jeffrey
soloway to
make his
reports
updating
from last time and
wherever you're comfortable
find the nicest chair
other than mine
by the way these are the cliff notes
i'll try to be brief but please
understand that for a former academic
saying hello is a 30-minute lecture
this
is in some ways
a memorial
a week ago today
we laid to rest representative catherine
rogers
um who
was
simply a tireless
member of the house of representatives
that's a little difficult to talk about
and it was her
wish
for the legislature
to examine the place of precision
medicine
in the state
and to use the powers of the legislature
to advance the concept of precision
medicine
as a result of her efforts
the chairman appointed an interim
subcommittee we were interim
to examine the issue of precision
medicine and to make a recommendation
with regard to
the likelihood
or necessity of
a
permanent subcommittee of dhhs oversight
to examine the issues of precision
medicine
so um the
chair appointed the
representatives and council
listed on this document as a temporary
subcommittee
to
create this report
i must say that
the initial draft of this report
which i authored
was deemed by the temporary subcommittee
to be an extraordinary example of
academic overreach
and
i was
instructed to as one would say
kick the can
down the road and come up with a
two-page recommendation and anything
else that i cared to include might be
included in an appendix
i did not exactly kick the can i turned
a little pale
instead i hope that
doesn't spill over
into your sense of humor the chair uh
caught each pun thank you
um so um
the
uh committee took
the goals of um
representative rogers initial
legislation and transposed them into
this document you will find that at the
bottom of page one and on through page
two
there is an attempt to define precision
medicine
um
and on
at the bottom of page two and then
beginning on page three the middle of
page three
basically are the recommendations that
um we implement a task force on
precision medicine composed of
two senators
one from each of the major parties three
members of the house of representatives
two from majority one from minority uh
members who will have demonstrated
interest in health care the commissioner
of health and human services
commissioner are you still here um uh or
an appropriate designee
commissioner of insurance or an
appropriate designee
a representative of a not-for-profit
citizen advocacy group
an example might be the new hampshire
cancer society and i would point out
that the cancer society has been a very
constructive
advocate for the search for
new solutions in the areas of cancer and
is probably an appropriate appointee
representative of
reimbursement
and that would mean
we have to have the insurers at the
table a representative of the medical
society the nursing association and
i probably should have included
the hospital association
and
i i apologize for that oversight and
i'll have to fix that
um
so the instructions to the task force
are included beginning at the bottom of
page three and on page four and
endlessly beyond
is the appendix
with what are
my manipulative recommendations for the
kinds of things that
the task force should be looking at i'd
like to point out that there are two
philosophical issues that arise in this
um
and my colleagues on the
interim subcommittee
have instructed me well in this area
need to understand that modern medicine
is a little over a hundred years old
it was only with the publication of the
flexner report in 1910
uh sponsored by the carnegie commission
that we moved from
practicing what i would call inductive
medicine well let's see what works and
we'll try it here to deductive medicine
where we said we need to base medicine
in contemporary science and over the
last 120 years we have pushed that basic
science to lead us in the direction of
what is now precision medicine
that philosophical shift
to science-based medicine now blossoms
with the concept of precision medicine
that's described for you in the appendix
and i won't burden you with my discourse
on that
having said that there's another
philosophical challenge that awaits us
on health and human services oversight
and in the legislature and that is what
is the appropriate role of the
legislature
in
managing
the entry of this new form of medical
practice
into
our health care industry here in new
hampshire
do we have an obligation to assist
entrepreneurial efforts should we be
assisting the development of new science
should we be
regulating reimbursement for the
services that are available should we be
finding ways to guarantee that those
with limited insurance have access to
precision medicine or
my friends
should we simply take on our normal
regulatory role and permit an
entrepreneurial system within
the uh
academic medical centers
and private industry to lead this
forward
that's an interesting philosophical
question which i assume we will debate
and we will come up with our
suggestions for the state legislature
um at this point i would like to hand
this report over to the chairman for his
wise implementation of its
recommendations as he sees fit and thank
you for patiently listening
i want to say sir thank you for your
work and i find the appendix to be
really cool
because if it were a hot appendix would
have to take it out
thank you for your sharp comments sir
i do have a question on the membership
of the task force
i hardly agree that the hospital
association should be
one of the ones listed
i also wonder if there is a place for
alumni house
and senate persons who do not otherwise
fit in under any of these categories and
the reason is i'm already doing advanced
planning for who might be in my
health human services and elderly
affairs committee going forward because
i have already heard six of the 21
members will not be running again and so
as i'm trying to think about
how are we going to
staff that i also see that there will be
a brain drain from my committee
and wish that at least some of those
brains might be folded into this task
force
so those would be a couple of
changes i might like to make
on the staffing on this issue does
anyone else have any comments
on who should be represented here
so mr chair i have i have to just
restate
a belief that
five to seven is kind of the ideal
number of people on any committee if you
want the committee to to do work
um and and maybe a concept to consider
is to is to limit
the thou shall appoint
such and such
to like a maximum of seven
and then include a at the discretion of
the chair
others may be invited to give you the
discretionary subject matter expertise
at the table
thoughts on that comment
representative soloway i i agree with
representative edwards typically so
and i think that there's room for
ex-officios and given that we have a
full oversight committee that could be
the larger
audience for the report of the task
force that would provide a wider point
of view i think he's quite correct that
seven is kind of maximum to be agile and
active
well i find 11 even before we've invited
the hospital association or anyone else
so the question is who would be removed
i would offer that you could remove one
senator because i don't think this is
partisan i think this is this transcends
any partisan issues and
you know we already as almost as a rule
in the senate wherever bill comes with
two members we reduce it to one
in most cases
is it your thought representative
soloway that work product would find its
way to oversight before it goes on its
way yes absolutely okay
so then we would get the bipartisanship
in places where it would no longer exist
would you think then two members of the
house one and one yes
well we're down to nine
which was not meant to assume the
hospital association has been dropped if
we include the hospital association mr
chairman i get 10. that's what i get if
we do okay
well
just as a disclaimer i offered an
organizational theory i don't i don't
think it's a rule it's just a thought to
if we go over seven we just need to
aware we're becoming a little uh
clumsier and less flexible
representative soloway do you see that
let's call it gang of ten for the moment
uh breaking into a few subgroups for
particular things to report bark to
their larger group
which would take it out from being as
unwieldy
i'll uh redraft that section mr chairman
and have that to you by monday
would you suggest that the hospital
association is very definitely part of
absolutely and unequivocally uh ms
minahan my apologies for not including
the hospital association initially
and alumni house and senate members
could certainly be brought in as expert
witnesses or co-opted i have that with
my deaf and hard of hearing commission i
literally do not know
the people sitting around the table
whether they're members or just they
show up all the time
but they get a good voice and uh we've
never voted because we always nod
and so it really doesn't matter that
much but if we ever had to i think i can
be told who the core people are who are
allowed to vote
so
on your desk monday mr chairman thank
you representative
nelson
10 heads better than seven
looking at this
yeah we've got ted
i would think so somebody mentioned that
i deal with seven people
well i guess i'm supporting the idea of
having ten which would be the
okay
all right that's one item on this um
other aspects of his report
representative edwards
so napoleon used to
have his generals write
operations orders and and then they
would be read to the corporal that was
standing outside the tent standing guard
usually an illiterate individual
and the rule was that unless napoleon's
corporal understood the order
they had to go back and simplify it and
rewrite it so
standing as
the
napoleon's corporal in your committee
i i do appreciate the the reformatting
uh i i think i think it just will make
more sense but um as i'm looking at the
appendix
i'm i'm seeing
uh the implication
that clinical effectiveness will be a
part of our assessment of of uh the
technologies but i don't think i read
the word clinical effectiveness anywhere
i just i'm curious if it's if you think
it's necessary is it embedded in some of
these other aspects or should it be its
own category i don't know
representative
i take a page from your book
in terms of
whether the legislature has a role to
play in the relationship between
professional and patient
and clinical effectiveness is a
determination that i think ought to be
made by the professionals and not the
legislators
and sir you have been a fine general
disciplining
all of us corporals
anyone else
i may not have seen it i may have
skimmed over it
is there a
very concise statement of purpose for
this group what is the job
it looks like a lot of academic
investigation which is fantastic always
measure before you cut particularly in
surgery but is there a specific task
that this group
this task force will do uh page two sir
the task force shall and there is a list
of
five items that the task force will
accomplish
wonderful thank you let's take a look at
that
would you include at this point
a discussion if not a determination
of what the various roles of
the legislature and other groups might
be
in going forward with such information
i would suggest sir that it would be
the
obligation of the task force to make
recommendations to the oversight
committee and for the oversight
committee to then make its legislative
suggestions
to
the two houses
but i think that goes beyond
the
um
prerogatives of a task force
but making recommendations to oversight
would would you put that in yes as f yes
done
other thoughts other thoughts on the
report the duties represent senator
rosenwald thank you mr chairman
i'm on page three i note that down
toward the bottom you save members of
the task force will receive a mileage
allowance
for attendance as is the practice of the
house and senate i i think the practice
is that legislative members
get a mileage allowance and not all
members
um
i i believe senator that that's covered
by the verbiage
remember oh i see what you're saying no
members of the task force right okay
legislative members
legislative members that we got it
typically include and not
other members
i thought that was included under as is
the practice of the house and senate but
i'm certainly glad to include the word
legislative at the beginning and that
should be fine
senator is the assumption here
that the other members might be
reimbursed
by their work
if you're a member of
nursing association or
representative of the hospital
association they take care of
the mileage for people appearing here
i
wouldn't know how to make assumptions
about that i'm just not remembering
seeing
that all task force members
[Music]
get reimbursed by the legislature a
representative sampling of heads uh out
there indicates that at least some do
thank you you're welcome
so yeah that can be
tweaked anything else
now the chair would like to know how to
proceed
do we with the amendations additions
suggestions
approve this report and thereby
constitute this or
what representative soloway i would like
to move mr chairman acceptance of this
report with uh inventions and additions
second
anyone like to second this
senator gaida
now any further discussion
looks good
that there is none so would the clerk
please call the roll
what would be an alternative you can do
a voice vote i think but we can call the
role i'm perfectly happy to do that uh
senator rosenwald yes
uh senator guida yes
senator gray is no longer here or
representative mark pearson yes
representative edwards yes
representative soloway yes and
representative mcmahon yes and
representative nelson yes
uh i count uh everybody voted favorably
did you vote i i'm an alternate sir oh
you can nod
i don't believe that i qualify at least
at this point in time as the senator so
i uh
will uh can we get back to you on that
or you can do whatever you'd like
i'm trying to count the number of people
who actually voted
seven to nothing
the vote is seven to nothing
thank you all reports of
the
temporary committee is
received with gratitude especially from
its chair
and
you'll do the tweakings so we'll have
that
amended copy soon shoot it out to us by
email thank you very much and then i
believe it falls to
hi
oh would you like to speak
okay
i mean we are a friendly group
and i haven't greeted you yet today so
thank you mr chair members of the
oversight committee for the record uh
tom praise all from by the way not all
people get a fanfare yeah i know
it's my birthday um
play the song uh no uh we i'm here uh
today i just wanted to put a plug in for
senator prentice who's been working on a
new hampshire legislative cancer caucus
and their first meeting is going to be
on may 2nd where they're going to going
to hear a presentation from the american
cancer society on developments in the
use of biomarker testing and i thought
it was just appropriate to
inform the committee of this and there's
a notice in the senate uh calendar to
that with a link to join the meeting so
i'm happy to follow up with
members of the committee on a more
formal with via email of that meeting
but just thought it was apt timing so
i think it would be helpful if anybody
has people to nominate that
uh you send it to the oversight for
brief consideration and then it can go
on
with any recommendation or
recommendations to the president of the
senate and the speaker of the house so
thank you so much thank you uh mr mike
rollo from
hampshire cancer society emailed me this
morning indicating he would be
interested in
serving as well and others who are
listening at home
or in your office
and those of us here who have
suggestions
for nominations
you can always send them to me and i'll
make sure the whole committee gets it
and we'll spend a week or so batting
them around and
then i will go to the governor the
president and
the others are listed here how does that
sound
okay good thank you
all right
the chair recognizes weltened and well
vacationed needs no introduction after
that henry lippman
we've had a very strong uh
investment
in his getting off to vacation and
welcome back the ten is starting to fade
are you planning something this summer
and wally's still smiling too
and dr sarah finney
good morning
for the record henry lipman medicaid
director and
i'm working on my tan for next year
uh dr sarah finney medicaid dental
director
i guess we're here to probably tell you
news that you're more aware
than of us than than we are i guess
yesterday this the senate voted uh
24 to to nothing to advance the
um
hb 103
house version and
we greatly thank uh
the chair and representative edwards for
helping us work through the house
on that and senator
roosevelt working with you and
harmonizing the
legislation um
and
i see that we're on the docket for next
week in the senate to appear at uh
finance um
on that um and also i think we have on
422 senate bill 422 in the house
in finance um and there's anything that
you can share with us that you would
need for information from your
perspective as leadership on on these
bills um
we're really grateful for the work
that's been done
on it
we can talk privately i get a few
thoughts okay okay
um
anyway thank you
doctor
um i just didn't know if you had any
questions uh regarding exactly what the
benefit
design is at this point and what is
covered and not covered it has been
in my reports our reports to you you
know we have gone through all of that so
i don't know if anyone has any questions
at this point i'm happy to answer them
senator guida just to comment mr chair
that sitting on finance in the senate
i would ask you to have as sharp a
pencil as you can to be able to detail
the costs
for the relevant provisions in in the
dental benefit well okay absolutely
thank you thank you
senator rosenwald thank you do you know
at this point if the benefit will
require
a waiver from cms or just a state plan
amendment actually both um to do the the
denture provision the way we are uh
where it is waiver populations that are
covered by that that portion will
require a waiver and of course we will
have to do a state plan amendment okay
but we have you know again in our report
this month a timeline which may flux a
little bit depending on when legislation
is passed
but you know we're we are planning
exactly what steps have to happen so
that we have cms approval uh when it's
required okay
if i could just follow up reinforce the
reinforcement
sticking to the timeline so that
we could get to a benefit
within the biennium
believe me i want to see that happen and
then that is my intention and we will do
our best to meet all the deadlines that
we need to to achieve that otherwise
i'll work too long for this too
thank you
thank you i appreciate that
otherwise i just fear somebody's grubby
hand is going to try to push the clicker
back to zero and we'll have to start all
over again
so we can't do that
representative edwards
uh thank you mr chair uh
dr finney i you you addressed the waiver
and plan update required for the denture
component i understood um that something
was needed to be done also on the co-pay
aspect
i apologize yes there is also another
type of
waiver that is done for the cost sharing
but they're all we have already been in
discussion with cms and those things are
are lining up so so that's kind of my
follow-up you you already have had
verbal assurances from cms that they
want to support both of these aspects
yes because we did not want the
legislation to move forward if it wasn't
something that we could do
under cms guidance thank you thank you
senator guida
thank you mr chair
uh i've had expressions of concern from
a number of dental practitioners about
missed appointments
which is essentially a consumable that
is then perished
uh is there any
uh
language or
mechanism to address that issue and
perhaps to
remind recalcitrant or repeated
offenders if you will that the benefit
is not perpetual if you continue to miss
your appointments
the short answer is yes let me elaborate
a little bit
so the work group had dental
representation and that very concern was
very much on the table
built into the cost structure is a care
coordination component
and a transportation component so that
that precious commodity of dentist time
and empty chair is minimized to the
extent possible um and i think part of
you know i think
dentist's willingness to participate is
also
part of the funding include some
improvement in the fee schedule as well
anyone else for mr lipman and dr finney
you do okay representative edward so
thank you mr chair this is sort of a
follow-up to senator guida's uh
question and mr whitman's uh response i
i i
i think that the no-show issue
we talked about finding some way to
financially uh penalize people who
who didn't show
we we ended up rejecting that
um but because the uh the initial
checkups and cleaning
are exempt from the co-pay there's not a
financial barrier for people going and
getting a checkup
and then if they are diagnosed where
they need significant care uh for their
teeth then they they would have a
personal incentive to show up and so
i i might my hope is that we
experience
a kind of a level of no-shows
that isn't much worse
than the commercial marketplace that's
that's that's my belief going into this
that's the way it should play out
particularly with the extra supports
given the types of population served
that uh being built into the plan here
um
you know i have some experience when i
was on the provider side about the empty
chair issue so i can assure you that i
fully appreciate
what you're saying here
i i think the the only thing that i
would add to that is that you know
certainly i myself as a past practicing
dentist i am very you know aware of the
situation
and i think that it was important that
we come up with a solution that didn't
make the dentist responsible for trying
to chase down those patients and that
we're offering something on the plan
side that will support individuals
getting to the appointments and not
making that another burden for the
dentist
thank you so much
thank you
chair now recognizes nancy rollins
and the new kid on the block melissa
hardy
that i'm the old kid on the block that
would be i the word veteran and
experience there you go a fountain of
wisdom with institutional memory was
coming to mind
thank you good morning thank you
chairman pearson and members of the
committee
my name is melissa hardy i am the new
kid on the block so to speak as the
director for the division of long-term
supports and services so thank you for
having us this morning
thank you and for the record i'm nancy
rollins
i'm serving as an executive manager
working on special projects for the
department
and we're here today to provide an
update um on what the department is
calling the developmental disability
systems work project
um but i would like to begin by talking
about um putting this into a bit of
context relative to how it is that we
got to where we are here today
and i want to reference
three
studies
that were conducted over the past recent
history
in february of 2016 there was an a
legislative budget analyst
audit of the bureau of developmental
services around unspent appropriations
it was a performance audit
and in that their recommendations
included some 12 observations that
included such areas as
inefficiencies within the service
delivery system
insufficient management controls to
track certain
people on the waitlist and maintenance
clients
and a lack of management controls over
information technology systems upon
which the service delivery system relied
and so on and so forth
then in december of 2016 the centers for
medicaid and medicare services
sent correspondents to the state
whereas the center cms had determined
that new hampshire was out of compliance
with two areas with its service system
for people with
disabilities specifically people with
intellectual
developmental and acquired brain injury
and those two areas were direct pay and
conflict of interest regulations
the direct pay rule
has to do with the way the service
delivery system was designed and
operating in the state of new hampshire
and is today
is that
we contract out with the area agency
system and then they will subcontract to
a variety of vendors and other providers
to provide services
in order to receive reimbursement the
provider works back through the area
agency and the area agency is the entity
currently that bills directly
to the medicaid system
cms called foul and said that anyone who
is a medicaid provider should be able to
do a direct bill
so that became a focus of work the
second part under cms was what's called
a conflict of interest
and it's a violation
for those on 1915 c waivers
which is what is on medicaid
1915 c waivers so the intellectual
disability
acquired brain injury ihs waivers are
1915 c waivers
and they require the state to have
separate service plan development case
management providers from those who are
providing the direct service provision
so in other words you can't evaluate
determine what a person needs develop a
plan and then also provide the service
you must pass that on now there are ways
to do that
we do have independent case management
agencies that perform that service
and we do have some area agencies that
have set up separate corporations that
do have
the ability to have a firewall so that
they are considered not in conflict
but again this was a second study that
said that there are concerns
that need to be taken into consideration
with the dd system
and then thirdly
there was
published in february of 2020 the
governor's commission on disabilities
analysis and report
by a committee to study the state's
system of very long title the dd system
in essence and make recommendations
thereof
it was as the request of house bill 2
and the committee which was a broad
group of stakeholders including family
members
advocates lobbyists and others
interestingly many who are on the
current
advisory committee for the current
project
were part of that study
coming out of that study
there were some 13 target improvement
areas
the group met extensively throughout the
fall of 2019
and published in
early spring this study that came out
some of the areas that were highlighted
was the need for intensive treatment
services
transition supports and services we
identified several operational
efficiencies that needed to happen
within the uh service system
they needed a quality workforce
uh waiver considerations and concerns
relative to that
and perhaps most importantly
system cost curving the committee
recognized that there was an imperative
to look at the future of long-term
services and supports
by improving areas where costs had grown
at an accelerated rate
in recent years
and is expected to rise
disproportionately so really was
optimal to get your hands around what
was going on in this service system and
look at addressing some of the
inefficiencies with how the service
system was operating
then serendipitously in 2020 the
department contracted with alvarez and
marcel
to do a study of the department and to
identify and make recommendations
relative to certain efficiencies that
could help within the department
to address a number of
factors and uh
what happened from that is that the
department did contract with alvarez and
marcel and work began in the early fall
of 2021
and we're here today to give you a bit
of an update in terms of where that work
is
and give you a sense of what
has gone on
if you would turn to the
well it's actually the first slide
past the title it's page two
that has as its headline dd systems work
original findings
some of you who we were able to meet
with
in late fall
may recognize the scatter graph that's
on the left hand side
and what this demonstrates
um each of those dots actually
represents a person
um and it the x-axis is measuring the
person's assessed level of support that
they need
um
and how their high their needs are and
then the y-axis is measuring how much
funding each person actually received
during a fight a fiscal year
in an ideal world we'd like to see a
much more tight relationship between a
person's level of need and their funding
but as you can see in this scatter graph
that's obviously not what's happening
here
so this is an indication that there are
reasons why we need to do a deeper dive
and get our hands around what is going
on
with identifying people's needs and
matching that up with appropriate
funding issues
there are systems issues
on the right hand side that have been
identified
are really three areas information
technology
operational and policy
and it makes the very challenging for
the department
to monitor and adjust service provision
to support the people
for whom we are mandated to be serving
and so the data indicates that some
recipients do not receive service
funding that really aligns with their
assessed level of need
the
service system providers are reimbursed
with rates that are have not been
updated in more than a decade
and
the bureau of developmental services is
operating with an antiquated
siloed information technology systems
which do not allow adequate reporting on
monitoring or timely assessing
and so this then has become the focus of
the work that we've been focused on with
alvarez and marcel
and i'll turn to my colleague
so just drawing um your attention to the
third slide there
to better serve individuals and protect
our federal funding we need significant
updates to our current operations
policies in its system as nancy said
so for our waiver updates
to improve the supply and quality of
services available
we're amending our medicaid 1915 c
waiver to have more specific service
definitions
because our current waiver is very broad
it has very broad service definitions
providers and area agencies across the
state deliver services in different ways
and sometimes don't deliver services
because there's not a policy for funding
those services or to support that idea
so this can lead to
inequities
and limited services for people with
developmental disabilities
by improving those service definitions
and increasing the types of services
available
our intent is to improve the quality of
services and the supply of services and
the consistent delivery of those
services
we want to ensure that whether if
somebody lives here in concord or lives
in conway they have access to the same
high quality services and provided in a
way which makes sense in their community
improving service definition is also
imperative to the rate setting work
that
to ensure that rates more directly align
with the services that are being
provided
so the department is developing a new
rate methodology that will be based on
up-to-date data
the intent of this change is twofold
first
it's important to update the
reimbursement rates to more accurately
reflect the cost of providing services
so that providers have
adequate resources to render those
services and secondly we're
transitioning to rates that will be
based on an individual's
level of need
so to assess an individual's level of
need the department will be using
the supports intensity scale otherwise
known as the cis assessment to inform
this work for rate setting
this is a tool that's been used in new
hampshire previously but only for
planning and not for individual
budgeting
we're developing rates so that a
person's cis assessment score will
inform the reimbursement amount that
providers receive
for delivering a service to that
individual
by more closely aligning reimbursement
rates with individual support needs we
will be better able to ensure people
have access to the right level of
funding to purchase those services
whether they have low service needs or
high service needs
structuring rates in this way will also
significantly increase the amount and
type of data the state has available to
support budget forecasting and fiscal
fiscal control
another key component of our rates work
is the transition to direct bill as
nancy was talking about
cms has required that all developmental
disability providers enroll with
medicaid so they have the option to bill
services directly or use a third-party
biller
completing this enrollment will ensure
that new hampshire does not lose our
federal funding and it will empower
providers to enter the service delivery
system directly
for the information technology the new
system including direct bill and updated
rates will not be operational without
the support of a modernized i.t system
we're contracting with deloitte to build
a new it system for the bureau
area agencies providers case managers
and individuals will benefit because
some of our slowest plot processes
currently will become automated
the department will also have access to
better data we'll be able to track data
such as time to service and actual spend
which will help us monitor
the system and correct inequity should
they arise
uh representative edwards for a question
on this point
so so you caught my attention when you
said deloitte was building an i.t system
does that mean you're not using a
commercial off-the-shelf product in any
way that they're writing unique code
only for new hampshire
yeah we are working with new heights um
which is a current system that we use so
deloitte and new heights and our um
systems teams are working together to
create that system follow up
okay so there there is a commercial
product
and you're tweaking the product exactly
and it's the product that the
department's been using for the last at
least 20 years so we are feeding into
that we're taking the four antiquated
systems and reworking them and and then
one other
um
this
cis score
seems critical
i'm just curious if there are underlying
algorithms within new heights that
generate the cis score or if this is an
individual going into the system and
doing an off sheet calculation and then
inserting
what they determine the score to be how
how is that cis score
calculated
well and i don't mean how i'm not
looking for the math i'm just looking
for if it's done by a computer algorithm
or if it's done
mostly due to human intervention
it hasn't been done by a technological
algorithm to date because we had not
been using it
in order to
make determinations relative to a
relationship or a correlation to cost of
care
so but we are
contracting out with the national
organization that actually uh oversees
the sis and we'll be doing some 400
samples relative to that and as part of
that we'll be looking at how we want to
roll that into the the technology that
we are working on relative to the system
i mean it would make um complete sense
to have a technological uh answer to the
algorithm there's no question so that
some of the
subjectivity if you will
were removed from that
it is not the only tool that we look at
in terms of what kind of supports people
need there is a medical
review also
that looks at some of the behavioral
challenges as well
um and we are continuing to work on that
as we go forward but i understand the
absolute necessity of of your question
so so um with within uh the kind of the
norming you also we also want to have
consistent approaches throughout the
entire patient population right so
that's the that's a key goal so
subjectivity is a little bit of a threat
to that absolutely and it always is in
terms of any of these evidence-based
tools so yeah we want to i i i do
appreciate your answer thank you
representative mcmahon
thank you mr chairman um ms rollins in
the interest of bringing it to the
ground ground level your guidance on
uh
these the cis
um algorithm would that be the right
description
or the cis scores yes
scores
okay and um
would that
therefore require a change in how the
iep and the isp would be
reported to qualify for said funding
um it would be taken into account
because part of this is
um as you know
you know we do the evaluations
assessments are done
um that
tool will be utilized in terms of
looking at the overall care plan and
then working that relative to the cost
of care um that will be applied so it
will all sort of be interrelated and uh
rolled in together
follow-up follow-up
and with that
to get the benefit of your guidance
there would that um indicate that the
area agencies would need that would not
need
would have a requirement of a new
paradigm for information gathering id
like for like for an iep so that it
would correlate with the funding um
qualifications
yes so the area agencies service
providers providing services to clients
would in essence have a new paradigm
relative to it is a tool that we've used
in the past but how it's being applied
uh for client care um and cost of care
uh will be different and so okay and
then just in closing on that uh is when
uh then what's your target for when that
is available so that when the
uh qualification for funding it that the
documentation meets what you require to
for this for the cms to give their
blessing yep and so you'll see on the
next page there's a timeline um that
will melissa will go through um it is we
need to do the 400 uh sample
first
but everything is part of those
milestones and i also want to say that
in all of this work
from the beginning and it has been
unprecedented in my experience the
amount of stakeholder involvement
relative to doing this work
both from the actual providers as well
as many of the vendors but certainly
family members and self-advocates this
is an important
but very significant
change to how the service system does
its business
it doesn't change the value system that
exists within the dd program
it doesn't change the statute that has
the underlying values of our service
system what it changes is how we do
business and for any of you in any
industry change is hard
change is confusing
change is going to be met with
resistance and other
thoughts and concerns
but we are working this with
stakeholders as best we can
and continuing forward it is the right
thing to do
to get our arms around this service
system
that as you hear from what i stated at
the beginning has been under scrutiny
for a significant period of time in
terms of how it operates and to put it
bluntly we need to bring it into the
21st century
so sorry for the
opinion
i think would agree
representative marsh
thank you mr chairman my
question relates to the 915c waiver
requirement that there be separate case
managers from those providing the
services uh is this an issue in new
hampshire at this point in time we're
not adequately implementing that and can
you elaborate please so we're under a
corrective action
plan um and we have an extension
again everything like the world um was
significantly impacted in our timelines
with covid 19. so we um
must correct this by june of 2023 we're
under an extension but we are working on
a corrective action plan and it is
rolled into the work that we're doing
with alvarez and marcel
um and to that point um which just flew
out of my head um
there was another part of that and i'll
probably need to come back
right i i wanted to to know and and i
think you've answered this you may
we're under a corrective action plan
because we're not currently implementing
the separate correct a case manager
requirement correct um
my follow-up question relates to senate
bill 333
do we have to be very careful that we
don't confuse the definition of the
providers and the case manager so that
you can actually implement this correct
action but we do have to be careful that
we're not confusing
things and i think we need to keep that
as simple as possible
and it only applies to the 1915 c
waivers
this conflict of interest matter is not
anywhere else in targeted case
management or in the other areas of the
healthcare industry it is only subject
to the 1915 c waivers and so that is
largely the area agencies and yes the
work that we are doing with them is to
make those distinctions as to what
function they will provide whether
they'll have that oversight and
evaluation and assessment component
and or be a service provider
so we are working with them as
organizations um in in a variety of
arenas
thank you that's very helpful
if you'd like to continue your report
thank you um continuing on slide three
for the last box for intensive treatment
services
the bureau is responsible for serving
individuals with varying and differing
needs
including this are individuals with the
most complex care needs
being diagnosed with a developmental
disability and dually with a mental
health
or behavioral health concern
so traditionally these were services are
referred to as intensive treatment
services or its
given the more complex supports that are
required
unfortunately due to the state lacking
capacity
many of these individuals that are
requiring its services are served out of
state at the current time
so
with the increasing federal pressure as
well as the commitment to serve people
in new hampshire locally
this has led to an expedited schedule to
develop a transition plan
for those served out of state so the
bureau
along with area agencies have started
working on transition planning
activities for a targeted group of
individuals as well as starting to view
a long-term in-state capacity
for those who are acquiring its services
and then lastly on the last slide um
slide four
which gives our timeline and and what to
expect
so we've provided a sample of our major
activities from last year and show the
work that we expect to complete between
now
and next summer
a major part of our work as nancy said
is stakeholder engagement the department
recognizes the magnitude of planned
changes in the developmental services
delivery
understandably stakeholders have
questions about the work
we understand that our timeline and our
work plan may be overwhelming to some
and the department welcomes input and
recommendations by all of our
stakeholders in an attempt to learn from
stakeholders and encourage them to shape
the work the department has stopped a
robust stakeholder engagement process
so this includes a series of monthly
work groups focused on the high priority
topics of this work including
self-advocates family members advocacy
groups and providers are developing
implementation recommendations to the
department for our consideration
stakeholders are deeply invested in the
system and some feel that this level of
engagement is not sufficient we're doing
our best to be responsive to all of
these concerns by incorporating their
suggestions into our stakeholder
engagement plans for example
in the month of may we as the department
will be going out to the community to
have in-person meetings across the state
that will give community members direct
access to the department of
representatives representatives to ask
questions about this work and discuss it
so we are planning those
as we speak
it is impossible to implement every
suggestion that we're given however
we're diligently trying to respond to
people's feedback and have meaningful
conversations
with people impacted by the work we take
our stakeholder feedback and input
seriously and appreciate their
dedication to make the system stronger
for individuals and their families
together with our community members
we're making progress on system
improvements we have onboarded the
vendor who will help us develop our new
rate methodology this group is myers and
stauffer and we're currently working to
collect the data we need
for the new rate development which would
include the cis scores
with the waiver work group we started
drafting revised service definitions
and this is include identifying
innovative and new service options to
better align
with the supports individuals and
families want to receive
so in the next few months we're going to
work on completing the sample round for
cis assessments
these cis assessments will be the sample
that myers and stauffer again use to
inform these new rates
and we're also going to review a series
of recommendations around how to
strengthen the direct support
professional workforce
we have a stakeholder subcommittee
and is currently developing some of
these recommendations
and towards the end of this calendar
year the first round of it upgrades will
go live
by next summer we anticipate launching
the direct bill so meeting the
compliance for the conflict of interest
corrective action plan
and submitting the waiver application to
cms
so so far our system work is on track
with our calendar and we appreciate your
support while making these changes to
benefit our families and individuals so
thank you for your time
mercedes you've only been here a couple
of months and yet we see such great
progress keep it up thank you very much
senator guida
with a question thank you mr chair um in
your stakeholder group
is the brain and spinal cord injury
association incorporated therein
um
trying to think of our members we have
our members posted on our website um
right we also have uh self advocates and
family members um i would have to check
specifically i would ask that you
incorporate them because that is a that
is a population that has some dreadful
needs that are absolutely yeah yeah
thank you
although
i do have to say a number of those
individuals are served under the choices
for independence waiver and not
necessarily the developmental services
and individual
intellectual disability
so we've really focused on those
populations in terms of most of the
steering committee
but we'll we'll look into it thank you
senator rosenwald
thank you mr chairman i do have a few
questions if i could
um
specifically you i think you mentioned
that you would be doing individualized
rates
for services
would that
encourage
a provider to cherry pick
the
clients that have the highest
rates higher rates for the same service
so if if
i don't know a home visit
is
eight dollars for one client and twelve
dollars for another client why wouldn't
the provider
uh
show preference to the higher rate
client well it's the it's not that the
individual rate will be different it's
the if you will menu of services
ultimately that's provided to the client
that will be different in terms of the
level of support
so
the one correlation is more that the
person who has the higher intensity
needs
usually with very challenging behavioral
issues
will have a higher budget because
they're going to need a broader variety
of services to support them in the
community
so that's more the reality i must have
understood what you
incorrectly what you said
um
i know you've said to us
and i've
seen it reported that while you want to
improve rates
you don't you won't be cutting services
but you don't expect
the budget the full budget that we need
to appropriate for to increase
i i don't understand how that
is going to work mathematically
how are we not going to see
a higher total
program cost
if we increase rates and don't cut
services
i think part of the work here is that
it's premature to speculate about that
at this point um as you know in going
back to the 2016 lba audit but so going
forward we've had
unexpended funds
in that area for a variety of reasons
but quite frankly
with the challenge of the it systems
being unable to clearly get an accurate
picture
um as to what the expenditures are and
what's being
provided to clients um it's it's um
challenging to to scope that out
so
um the
statement to uh clients is that um at at
this point in time we are not changing
their um
care plans um and the reason i say at
this point in time is because one of the
things that's working um under this
waiver is looking at are there some
other types of services that should be
identified and developed and be part of
the menu that currently we don't have
and some of that is in particular in our
housing options where we need to get
much more creative as to what community
housing looks like
just as an example
but in looking at that
and the rate structure that we're doing
i mean we do need to make sure that the
true cost of care are getting closer to
the reimbursement rates i mean we have
to be committed to that if we're ever
going to achieve quality um but all of
those things are the work that we're
doing but i think it's really premature
at this point senator to say whether or
not the funding that's currently in the
service system is sufficient or not to
do what we want to do
but the bottom line is we've got to do
this work in order to get our hands
around it so
what i'm hearing is we might be looking
at a more expensive program
in the next budget or the budget after
that or not i'm not saying that
definitively at this point at all it's i
think again it's too it's premature um
to have an answer to that until we get
these systems up and running and we get
a better handle on it or perhaps we just
want lapse funds
that we've exactly
but i think the other significant piece
is bringing home the folks who are
intensive treatment needs and developing
those resources here in new hampshire
that alone will be much more efficient
from a financial standpoint let alone a
quality of care standpoint
thank you and um if if i could miss
church you're on a roll senator go for
it i have some correspondence
um from march
from the developmental services quality
council which is
legislatively charged with
looking over
our dd system to make sure
that that it's good
and
they have expressed
a number of concerns
with
both the department's
approach towards transparency of the
work that's being done
and also
in the areas of
the waiver development and redesign the
budget and funding
and
the department's ability to help clients
seek employment
the last letter they sent to the
department was stated march 16th
has the department responded to that
letter in
either
generally or in detail to the areas of
concern or if not when
yes in in both ways one we are actively
engaged with the quality council
interestingly
excuse me many members of the quality
council are also on the advisory
committee for the alvarez and marcel
work
and a number of those members were
actually part of the governor's
commission report
going back in 2020 where they
specifically said and recognized as a
group that we needed to
look at hiring a consultant
to modernize the service system for
developmental services
we have self-advocates on that and
family members we are
very respectful
of their comments and recommendations we
have a very long list of frequently
asked questions that's on the website
there is a dedicated website for
information and transparency
all of
the meetings are on
zoom
and
you can certainly look at those the
transcripts are on
line as well as i stated i think before
um
we i believe have been exhaustive um in
being transparent and and involving
people as much as possible uh in this
process but as i also stated earlier
change is hard
and change is going to
produce a lot of concerns and we try to
address them and take them into account
but we also need to move forward with
this work
if i could just
one one more thank you the list of
stakeholders on the
developmental services quality council
does include the brain injury
association but it also includes a
member of the department
um in addition to
the institute on disability the area
agencies families who's
who are served by the system
and i just would encourage the
department to
listen to their concerns and respond to
them
and we do senator
we do actively engage with the quality
council in addition to all of the other
groups
melissa and
cindy hunt who's the bureau chief for
developmental services was on vacation
so that's why she's not here
are about to begin a series of in-person
meetings with all of the family support
councils
connected to the area agencies so
there's a tremendous amount of outreach
and transparency that's going on in this
project i'm really glad to hear that
because
this is an important constituency for
all of us no question and
from what i hear they're not happy
so
i hope you will
continue to listen to them and to
respond to their concerns absolutely
thank you mr chairman
thank you senator and everyone
i have a draft copy of next month's
amendment agenda
and we will be looking at the dd and the
acquired brain disorder weightless
quarterly report with sandy hunt melissa
hardy she's been promoted to a regular
thank you
any other questions
uh representative edwards uh thank you
mr chair i i i i think if you're gonna
use this uh timeline slide the on slide
four so there's you got a minor typo
there you wanna clean up the the last
group under the timeline says june 22 at
the far right
at that is probably 23. it is thank you
okay that's that's not why i mentioned
it though uh what what i was looking at
is that your sk it looks like you're
planning to submit the cms waiver
application
within 30 days of wanting the the pilot
project to go live
to switch from being a pilot to a go
live
and i'm just curious about
how
is that cutting it too close or is that
the normal amount of time
before you would want to submit a cms
waiver before wanting to go live with
the system
they're um related but somewhat separate
in that one is the billing process which
continues anyways
and then the waiver
permission is a separate process with
cms
does that make sense uh it probably does
to somebody who knows more about it i'm
just i'm just looking at this critical
date
doing a uh taking your pilot direct bill
project to full go live at the start of
fy24 which is july one right
and so then when i look up and i say
submit a cms waiver application i'm just
curious
to what extent the the
the go live is dependent upon that
waiver
it is not all right and then i'm sure
you got a risk mitigation plan under all
of this what how how confident are you
that you're going to be able to hit one
july
well given all the risks that you're
aware of
um it is uh
we are extremely optimistic that we can
hit this
we must
for the direct bill component
the waiver aspect
we will
you know
do that as well it's a matter of
things like getting the contract out for
doing the cis assessments with the local
group and those things that
as you say
can hold things up but we are very
optimistic that we will hit this all
right well thank you good luck
one question anyway um i've done a fair
bit of work with area agencies nine and
ten and through that got to know
jonathan roulard who has moved on um who
is this replacement
there's an interim uh at this point it's
ellen mcmahon okay is filling in as the
interim for the um community support
network thank you
um and just just
to connect a few dots here um counselor
edwards we passed a bill yesterday and
i defended it from the floor
saying that
rather than just spending a bunch of
money on something we're not familiar
with there is a pilot project
that will be assessed
um to see how well it works and to see
that it is of course quite cost
effective i don't remember the numbers i
just walked up there and said that um
if you know what i mean and he probably
knows more than what about what i mean
than i know uh could you say more about
that pilot project
you may want to come up and help me
eighteen
thank you
um so this uh bill 430 is for the 18 to
21 and a half year olds who currently
the gap right from school service to
developmental services right so we agree
um you know looking at a clubhouse model
perhaps for these folks as far as you
know getting them the services and
assessment that they need
and filling the gap between school and
the waiver program so we're really
grateful for your support on that
thank you
and say a little bit more about that
program um i i don't know much about it
i know that
okay but i can certainly um get you more
information on it um
certainly you know we know it's an
important gap in service that we want to
see you know what works as far as the
pilot and what would be cost efficient
for the state to get these folks the
services that they need that's about the
first thing i heard when i started
working with dd several years ago is
that gap
and i'm so glad to see that
we passed 4 30 and i hope in the uh
committee of conference reconciling our
version with the senate's version
that one had better stay in we hope so
thank you for your support yes thank you
any other
questions
thank you thank you and
new kid we'll see you next month
welcome
and then the last item is the
therapeutic cannas medicine cannabis
medical oversight board annual report
by a friend of some standing michael
holt who we see a lot
and it looks like we see you next month
too
that's correct
uh good morning
mr chair members of the committee my
name is michael holt i'm the program
administrator for the therapeutic
cannabis program within the division of
public health services
i am here on behalf of the therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board
chairperson representative jerry kanerk
he sends his regrets
um it's a long drive on a friday from uh
from up up in the mountains so i'll be
presenting the uh the the annual report
the board was very active in 2021 they
met 10 times both remotely due to covet
and in person once that option became
viable uh the first half of the year
they spent focused on legislative
initiatives
the board supported legislative efforts
to add qualifying medical conditions to
the statutory list
they based their recommendations on a
deep dive into the available medical and
scientific literature related to these
conditions
and the bills and the conditions that
were added that they recommend adding
were insomnia
autism spectrum disorder with specific
guard rails related to patient age
and opioid use disorder again with
specific guard rails based on the
medical specialties that could certify
for that condition so those were hp 89
and hb 605.
the board also supported legislative
initiatives related to providing more
education related to the therapeutic use
of cannabis including the risk of
cannabis use during pregnancy and while
breastfeeding
and the risk of cannabis use in
adolescents
the board supported a legislative effort
to require the atcs that stands for
alternative treatment center that is the
name of that the
new hampshire gives to the cannabis
dispensaries
to add the cultivar strain name to the
labels and other public facing documents
like like menus
prior to that they were required by
state regulation our rules to only use
uh abbreviations which became very
complex for the
patients to to do their own research on
cultivar um
effects if you will
um
lastly the board supported a legislative
effort to uh actually i just read that
one so all those initial initiatives
were passed into law
in 2021
so other work of the board in 2021
they continue to actively work on
provider education documents including
clinical best practices for medical
providers to consider and follow when
certifying patients for therapeutic
cannabis as well as education related to
specific populations
pregnancy adolescence and substance use
disorder
in addition the board reviewed the
requirements for the analytic testing of
cannabis uh for cannabinoids and
contaminants
they support efforts to update the
testing standards in the department's
rules to create efficiencies reduce
administrative burden and lower cost to
the atcs without sacrificing patient
safety
the board reviewed the atc's labeling
and packaging requirements and made
recommendations the board reviewed the
atc's educational materials and made
recommendations and many of these
recommendations have already been
adopted by the atcs
a theme of this year's work for the
board has been a focus on the patient
experience
the board has considered throughout this
past year issues affecting the state's
therapeutic cannabis patients issues
like cost of product product
availability accessibility
barriers to certification
employment issues among others
in fact the board unanimously voted to
engage in efforts to reduce the stigma
of therapeutic cannabis use
though to date specific activities for
this engagement have not been not yet
been identified or put into practice
this work did culminate in december of
this past year um when the board hosted
an advertised public in-person and
remote listening session to hear from
patients caregivers medical providers an
interested member of the public
about the issues that uh that that are
facing patients in new hampshire uh it
was well attended considering the winter
and um covid about 50 people
participated um and the board plans in
2022 to consider how it can engage to
support patients relative to the issues
they face
i would say that the board is a engaged
high functioning well respected by the
legislature
and a valuable asset to the therapeutic
cannabis program we uh we value their
existence in their in their council
um i'm happy to answer questions about
the the board's work last year
representative soloway
uh
good morning mr holt nice to see you
um thank you mr chair um this is a
a question
really regarding your experience and
wisdom that has a speculative uh
conclusion at the end i appreciate the
preface
we we um
are watching other states legalize
recreational marijuana
and i'm wondering
this would empower
users of therapeutic cannabis
to enter the recreational market
to self-medicate
and i'm wondering what impact that is
having in those states on the atcs
that exist there and what that might
imply
were we at some point in the future
to legalize recreational cannabis
can you speculate on that for me
yes uh of course i can
um
so
every state
that has legalized adult use
recreational cannabis
except for one has been able to maintain
the viability of their therapeutic
cannabis programs
in general
every state however has experienced a
decrease in the number of patients who
are registered in those medical programs
for exactly those reasons that you say
um
if it is legal then
why go through the administrative hoops
to register with the state talk to your
doctor when you can just go to a store
and purchase cannabis and and
self-medicate as you say
the importance of maintaining a
therapeutic program is is clear it
serves patients that are under 21 years
old
there are robust education
materials to on on dosages
what products work best for others there
are different products available which
target medical uses including cbd uh
products low thc products and cbd thc
ratio products um etc so there's a
and also there's there's a value for
medical programs in that they typically
have um a higher potency limit which is
needed for certain patients um than
adult use programs so
those principles apply the
the big the biggest factor probably
though is that other um
all other states that have legalized
have created a high tax model um and and
so that means medical cannabis is
typically
less expensive than recreational
cannabis and so
under the um because of that those
policy decisions
the uh the medical programs are can be
sustainable
now you know
15 household 1598 which just got a
hearing in
senate ways and means um yesterday two
days ago
that bill proposed a model that would
not have taxed uh therapy recreational
cannabis um and so the department was
very concerned that uh that that model
would undermine the um the therapeutic
cannabis model um
so
so yeah so in conclusion the
the
other states have been able to maintain
them um there is a model for
recreational cannabis that would allow
for the viability of a therapeutic
therapeutic cannabis program and
hopefully
if and when
new hampshire moves into that that space
we can successfully maintain the
therapeutic program
thank you mr holt i sought your wisdom
and you delivered perfectly uh thanks
for the work that you do
representative marsh yes thank you mr
chairman mr holt i just wanted to thank
the board for its work developing the
warning posters and pamphlets which you
worked on this last year uh and uh to
point out that those were intended from
the beginning to be more widely used
should new hampshire ever legalize
recreational campus
thank you representative i noticed your
amendment in house bill 1598 allow the
liquor commission to use the materials
that we're developing
representative edwards
this is a more general concern follow-up
on what representative salloway was
asking as i'm as i'm looking at the the
charter and the members
um
i i
i start to wonder
who we should be turning to routinely as
a legislature when we're concerned about
the longer term financial or economic
viability of the atcs i i've been
concerned for years i think you've and i
have talked about it uh about the
sustainability of the
atc model under their current structure
um
who or which group or is there anyone
chartered with uh officially assessing
and coming up with a
one year to five year sort of this is
where it looks like we're going
economically
representative there is not a an entity
that is
that is in charge of that there are
three licensed atc's um they are
required by state law to be
not-for-profit entities which is a
severe challenge
to their their business model their
ability to reinvest in their companies
and make improvements including lowering
cost
over the past several years legislation
has been
introduced that would remove the
requirement or allow the atcs to convert
to for-profit entities
like has happened in
most of the states that at first
required
therapeutic cannabis dispensaries to
adopt a for-profit model and to date
those legislative efforts have stalled
um in fact senate bill 38 this from the
201 2021 session
passed the senate
passed the house
was vetoed by the governor for the
second time
was overturned
in um this uh the veto override was uh
uh successful in the senate um and the
bill
um lost by 13 votes in the house
that
that bit alone would uh
would uh would let me sleep better at
night regarding their viability
but to your question there there's no
entity that is that is looking at their
viability um besides uh besides the
entities themselves and as the you know
as the as the entity that's
required to regulate them uh i'm i'm
concerned i'm concerned if uh that they
don't allow they can't get to be
for-profit and i'd be concerned with the
wrong legalization bill
well follow up okay so so i i hear you
saying that my my concern is is not just
paranoia that that given that we're
rolling getting if we roll it out it is
going to be a no tax or a low tax
uh recreational pot bill
that that does present a competitive
challenge to our atc model
which threatens their economic viability
and that there's
no one group that's responsible for
assessing
the economic viability of the medical
marijuana in the united in new hampshire
and and as a result we're flying a
little bit blind
that that that's my summary is that is
that accurate 1598
inf actually included a provision that
would have required
the liquor commission to directly
compete with the atcs not just benign
neglect you know it had a provision that
said it shall be the duty of the liquor
commission
to sell cannabis for therapeutic
cannabis for therapeutic use
um and so
we are uh
the therapeutic so in addition the
therapeutic cannabis law
um requires that there be four licensed
atc's if one of them were to uh go out
of business the department would be
required to
issue an rfp
basically put that license out to bid
so certainly we would have quite a bit
of work to do in order to fill that gap
if one of the atc's decided to cease
operations
the marijuana commission from 2018-2019
chaired by representative abrami made a
strong recommendation that any
legalization effort in the state would
have a specific pathway for the atcs to
to be engaged in um adult use
legalization 1598 did not have that it
had an allowance that they could create
a separate
for-profit entity and apply just like
anyone else
so i know i'm not answering your
question directly but these are the
issues
i i agree with your concern
i just don't know how to help you if we
don't get the right information at the
right times from the right group of
people to the right people
when when discussing the impacts of 1598
to with the atc's um i mean the
the question the question i ask is you
know at what number like what what
number of patients do you need and
to to remain viable
and
they're going to try to stay viable for
as long as they can but if they would if
the number of patients is reduced
to remain viable they have to increase
prices
um
one of the issues is that
there's 13 000 patients that they can
serve in the state
um not not a lot to make you know these
businesses uh viable uh more patients
means more sales means greater viability
um allowing them to be for profit uh
means greater viability um the patient
uh is about yeah about 13 000 patients
right now it hasn't grown this past year
it had you know between 2020 you know
2021 2022 um the patient growth has
stabilized um
so i don't know what the solution is
um
except for ones that have already been
tried which are to allow them to convert
to for-profit entities
there is not a bill this session that
would attempt to do that a third time
sing no further hands up thank you mr
holt and uh with
oh gosh three minutes to spare
adjourn this meeting and remember next
time we meet the third
friday of may may 20th at one o'clock in
the afternoon
you are just too darn possible you know
that
your dance card is
full 4.59
you